وبعد ذلك ، إذا كان بإمكاني القفز هنا ، فقد
انتهى الأمر ، إلى متى يمكن أن يستمر هذا ،
هذا هو السؤال ، خاصة أنه
يبدو أنه يزداد حدة ، فنحن نعلم أن
روسيا قد قدمت دعمًا كبيرًا
لهذين الرجلين في الماضي على وجه التحديد
القائد محمد رئيس
هناك قلق حقيقي من المجموعة شبه العسكرية
من أن المعدات الروسية والتدريب الروسي
يسمحان له بالصمود
ضد القوات المسلحة السودانية التي
تفوقه عددًا ، ومرة ​​أخرى تتحدث عن
حقد النفوذ الروسي في
كثير من إفريقيا وتحديداً في
السودان أن هذا قد حان.  حتى هذه النقطة ،
كان هذا في الحقيقة نتيجة
لعب القوة الروسية واستغلالها
لموارد الذهب في السودان ، حيث يمكن لشخص مثل
القائد محمد ، قائد قوة شبه عسكرية
مع امتداد طويل من
انتهاكات حقوق الإنسان باسمه ، أن يكون
في هذا الموقف لاحتجاز البلاد
كرهينة.  هل تعلم أن عائلتي في
السودان حاليًا فهذا أمر
مرعب للغاية وأنا أعلم أنهم في
وضع أفضل من هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين يعيشون من خلال ما
نعرضه على الهواء إذا كان بإمكانك التحدث إلينا
أكثر قليلاً  حول حصيلة
الناس ، هل هناك عائلتك ، تابع ، من فضلك
تحدث إلينا حول هذا ، لقد تحدثت إلى أمي
قبل أن أصل إلى الهواء مباشرة ،
نفد الطعام ، معظم المحلات مغلقة ، في
الواقع ، جميع المتاجر مغلقة ، والبنوك مغلقة
أغلقت كانت هناك محاولة في
ممر إنساني أو مطالبة في
ممر إنساني أمس عندما
تمكن أحد الأشخاص الذين يعملون من أجل والديّ من الوصول إلى المحل والحصول على بعض
الدقيق ، إنه أيضًا هذا الأسبوع الأخير من
رمضان.  في شهر رمضان ، تحدثت مع بعض
أبناء عمومتي الذين كانوا مستلقين على
الأرض مع أطفالهم ، وأقول
هذا مع وعي أن عائلتي لا تزال
محظوظة بشكل لا يصدق لأنهم
ليسوا في مناطق
أو معاهد عسكرية مجاورة حيث
كان بعض القتال  كان الأقوى
ولكن بصراحة ، هناك حامية على بعد أربعة
شوارع من منزل والديّ ، إذا كان
الأمر
مرعبًا حقًا ، أعني أن والديّ سيكرهون
أن أشعر بالعاطفة لأنهم
بالطبع غاضبون تمامًا مثل
الكثير من السودانيين وهم في الحقيقة
من المحتمل أن نكون متماسكين
بشكل أفضل من أولئك الذين عالقون في
الخارج ينظرون إلى هذا ولكنك تعلم أنه
يتعين علينا تذكير مشاهدينا بأن هؤلاء
هم نفس الرجال الذين خربوا
الديمقراطية الوليدة في السودان كما تعلمون أننا جميعًا
نتذكر تلك الصور لآلاف من
سيدني.  عشرات الآلاف من السودانيين
يخاطرون بحياتهم والآن هؤلاء
الرجال أنفسهم يحتجزون بلدًا بأكمله
كرهينة ويبدو أن العالم لا يستطيع إلا أن
ينظر
جيدًا إلى نعمة ، نحن نقدر صراحتك مع
أننا نتمنى لعائلتك
وكذلك أي شخص آخر شكرًا  أنت للمشاركة